léonard je peux entrer mais bien sûr
facteurs au contraire dépêchez vous
casimir est parti ce matin en bateau ils
font vite que vous menez un service
avant qu'il ne revienne qu'est-ce que je
peux faire pour que voilà voilà vous
allez prendre cette lettre et la porte
et un jus ni je vous donnerai 5 francs
enfin les renards tu te méprends sur le
métier du facteur ça c'est la meilleure
vous allez me dire que le métier d'un
facteur n'est pas de porter des lettres
enfin il y à l'être et lettres il ya
celles que portent les facteurs et puis
seul que portent les livreurs ou les
coursiers je ne vois pas la différence
assez pourtant très simples voilà si tu
veux faire porter une lettre par un
coursier ou un livreur
mais la lettre dans une enveloppe et et
tu payes le coursier pour que celui-ci
la porte où tu veux mais alors pour le
facteur là c'est totalement différent un
tutu mais un timbre premièrement sur l'
enveloppe et il faut que celui-ci soit
oblitérée au bureau de poste
et et un télégramme alors là c'est plus
rapide seulement il faut passer à la
poste un pour remplir une formule
également tu peux téléphoner le texte
c'est un texte se tresse alors je me
demande ce qu'en tant que facteur je
peux faire pour toi
oui mais en tant que facteur peut-être
mais pas en tant qu'ami aaa alors il
faut le dire tout de suite
j'oublie que je suis facteur
voilà c'est emile campagne qui te parle
alors en tant qu'ami je peux te rendre
ce service donne moi ta lettre je vais
la porte et achètent un an merci-facteur
vous êtes un ami extraordinaire se fait
vite âge je compte sur vous c'est promis
allez on a à bientôt à
tout préparer
vous reprendrez bien un sandwich
monsieur disney bien volontiers mes
chers amis cette idée de pique-niqué
merveilleux sac dès que nous avons su
que casimir et est absent nous avons
décidé de leur profil des naissains oui
je dois dire que bien que nous l'aimions
beaucoup lorsqu'il met des anchois dans
sa crème chantilly et de la choucroute
dans sa glace à la vanille c'est
difficile à supporter
vous dire qu'une journée sont casimir
une fois de temps en temps ça fait
plaisir
les amis bonjour
mademoiselle julie j'ai une lettre pour
vous mais une lettre personnelle donc
prenez mon plein ce facteur ça ce n'est
pas drôle
merci
il faut que tu viennes j'ai besoin de te
parler absolument
alors il doit se passer quelque chose de
grave à tout à l'heure je dois aller
chez léonard anjou
d'aujourd'hui
ne font pas être dit
leona je peux entrer au mais bien sûr je
me rends bien quelque chose qui ne va
pas armés comme c'est joli tu reçois des
amis merci enfin j'attends dit une amie
mais je n'attends plus personne puisque
tu es là tout ça en honneur mais julie
si moi qui suis honorée par la présence
acier 3,7 au fait c'est vraiment gentil
voici une marguerite que j'ai cueilli
pour toi ce matin dans le jardin de
monsieur martin merci les ânes à elle et
elle est ravissante
veux-tu un peu de thé et oui mais je
vais le servir
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un servir ou
aussi bien le tu es tu vraiment galant
leona que tu prendras peut-être quelques
petits fours
c'est à dire je n'ai plus très fin
comment tu n'as plus très fin du bien
non pour te dire la vérité quand j'ai
reçu la lettre nous étions en train de
pique-niquer tous dans le jardin
et tu n'as même pas pensé à me faire
signe tout le monde mon billet
hélas nous n'avons pas plié à la pause
de l'après midi avec toi
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]